the National Library of Medicine is
proud to present desalination a solution
for our water needs
did you know 97% of Earth's water is
saltwater from oceans hmm that's a lot
of water if there's so much ocean water
why don't we just drink the water I
don't get what everyone's saying about
all these water shortages and stuff it's
not that simple we can't drink salt
water why not what would happen if we
did drink it
well the salts in our food and drinks
ends up in our blood but we can't have
too much salt in our blood our kidneys
use water to flush out the extra salt
generating urine that exits the body
this is one of the reasons we need to
drink water but urine leaves the body
then getting rid of salt must cause us
to lose water from our bodies that's
correct
and what is sea water I guess it's just
water with a lot of salt dissolved in it
exactly so say you drink one cup of
seawater and saying that cup there is a
tablespoon of salt the amount of salt in
that cup of water is so hot that it
would take way more than the one cup of
liquid you drink to remove the one
tablespoon of salt from your body so
drinking seawater causes you to lose
even more water than you drink that's
right and losing too much water causes
dehydration which is very bad for you
it's such a shame there's so much salt
water if you could only get rid of the
salt we wouldn't have to worry about
water shortages or anything like that
well there is actually a way to remove
salt from seawater
it's called desalination and it's more
familiar than you think during the water
cycle water gets desalinated after a
rainfall the water flows toward the
ocean energy from the Sun causes the
salty water to evaporate leaving the
minerals on the ground the pure water
travels upward as a gas until it hits
cold air and condenses forming clouds
then fresh water falls as rain ho anak
condenses what's that
what is condensing it's when water gas
cools and turns into a liquid have you
ever thrown pictures on the bathroom
mirror after you take a shower the water
on the mirror came from your shower when
the water is hot part of it turns into
gas
then rises in the air when the gas comes
into contact with a cold mirror it cools
or condenses and turns into water again
clouds are just condensed water in the
air and those clouds produce rain
although nature produces fresh water it
is a precious but limited resource
desalinating ocean water provides
much-needed fresh water for people to
drink especially those in locations
without much so how do they do it
well there are two types of desalination
the first is called thermal desalination
thermal desalination is similar to the
water cycle salt water is heated that
evaporates leaving the salt behind the
evaporated steam is then cooled and
condensed into pure water like on a
bathroom mirror thermal desalination is
a good method because it works and can
handle large volumes however it does use
up a lot of energy another method of
desalination is membrane desalination
which uses semipermeable membranes a
semipermeable membrane is a thin sheet
of material with tiny holes that let
some amount of liquids such as water but
not solids like salt pass through it to
desalinate membranes are used in a
process called reverse osmosis this
process involves tanks divided by a
membrane pressure is applied to the
saltwater side forcing water through the
membrane from the side where there is
more salt to where there is no salt
since the membrane only lets liquids in
the salt gets left behind reverse
osmosis is more efficient than thermal
desalination meaning it produces more
fresh water for less money however a
reason not to use reverse osmosis is
that salt and other particles get stuck
in the membrane holes causing them to
stop working membranes also get old and
break down because of their short
lifespan membranes must be replaced
frequently which is expensive that makes
sense so if we have these technologies
why are there still water shortages
industrial desalination is not yet our
main source of drinking water because it
requires a lot of energy making it
expensive and harmful to the environment
furthermore harmful leftover salt is
hard to dispose of safely however
scientists have started combining
technologies to make desalination more
efficient such as using both membrane
and thermal desalination technologies
together and finding better ways to
power desalination plants so while we
have a long way to go
desalination really is a solution for
our water needs